et clairement ce qui s'est passé
dimanche c'est une honte pour beaucoup
d'entre nous on ne peut pas régler un
problème politique juste à coups de
police et à coups de justice malheur à
la rouille réellement a été totalement
insensible la cause fait plusieurs
années déjà qu'on a ce problème ils
ignorent totalement ce qui est train de
se passer en catalogne et ils envoient
la police régler un problème politique
en a besoin de dialogue maintenant et en
même temps on à l'autre côté on a plus
de montre effectivement qui continue sa
fuite en avant sur l'égalité donc on a
vraiment actuellement un double problème
c'est l'incompétence de la rouille une
plus qu une incompétence une incapacité
capacité de comprendre ce qui se passe
en catalogne et en même temps une fuite
en avant du verlan catalan dont on a
vraiment besoin l'union européenne
arrivent et disent voilà on va vous
mettre autour d'une table
il faut dialoguer parce que la seule
solution la politique c'est la médiation
européenne parce que là vraiment ça peut
être très très mal finir